ooh boy James Davis we're gonna make a
hood and jacent turkey sandwich now so
hood adjacent turkey sandwich because
it's gonna be simple but with a little
bit of fancy on it when you least
expected I can take my turkey sandwich
on to the golf course or say you kicking
somebody off the house get out of my
house but here's the turkey sandwich I'm
not evil I usually get my onion pre-cut
at the grocery store cuz I'm not a fan
of knives onions tend to make me cry
but I'm gonna keep it gangster white
bread I mean does it taste good
absolutely the wheat bread helps your
bowel movement and slice who needs that
we don't eat in slices any well we got
TV shows coming out I like to triple up
on my protein one another one another
one three of them turkey things and put
some onion in there because I need a
little bit of extra credit in there I
like the flavor coming from all
directions gotta have some good butter
lettuce once again for the bowel
movement I've eaten a lot of [ __ ] in
my life at this point in my career I'm
trying to put the bigness in there to
counteract all the skittles blunts and
whatever I do a Coachella every year
tomatoes once again gotta get my oj tool
just one thick piece boom we're done all
right have burger energy with my turkey
sandwich it's piling up with a
Flintstone sandwich but I'm gonna push
that thing down now we're going to put
the mayonnaise on adjacent the hood
doesn't mess with mayonnaise like that
so James does change lives
what is this these are mustard well done
I don't want that regular hotdog mustard
or fancy I'm staying at the Bowery okay
I'm living life
I need that Dijon mustard that's almost
empty when you have to do this and you
have to like kind of you get chefs
muscle into it and get the rest out and
then they start speed a little clearer
cuz it's a little old tool that's headed
mushroom now we're gonna put a little
bit of salt just a little bit though
because we're Jason the hood love salt
that's why the hood has a lot of high
blood pressure issues I just want to do
this but I can't afford that much salt
so I'm gonna do it outside of my
sandwich and I'm gonna put a little
pepper and guess what I'm trying to get
more swollen so Moe Turkey now my
sandwich is complete saucy and juicy up
top dry on the bottom and I always had
to give a shout out some to mom so I'm
gonna cut it let my mom cut the sandwich
diagonally there you have it you guys
are dried turkey and get the salty
turkey key and then you can see the
salad it's almost like there's a salad
in the middle of the sandwich so you can
see the healthiness going on this is
called the hoodie Jason because it looks
simple but then you peel this back and
there's a lot of nuance in here it's not
just a normal turkey sandwich if you in
the hood you got to be solid you can't
get pushed around cuz you gotta stay
dangerous this is a solid sandwich you
could drop this you can kick it it could
fall out your car you pick it up it's
still intact
I didn't want you guys to see the Beast
Oh
I've been into this thing like a inmate
he's been on the run for days and it's
still standing tall feel free to steal
my recipe everybody enjoy yourself 100
Jason turkey sandwich
look how started to stay dangerous